as an economic thinker as a writer
as a podcaster what do you think about
clubhouse
as what do you think about okay let me
uh just
throw my feeling about it i used to use
discord which is another service where
people use
voice so the only thing you do is just
hear each other there's no face you just
see a little icon
that's the essential element
of clubhouse and there's an intimacy to
voice only communication that's hard
that didn't make sense to me but it was
just what it is
which feels like something that won't
last for some reason maybe it's the
cynical view but what's your sense uh is
it
about this mat the intimacy of what's
happening right now with clubhouse
i've greatly enjoyed what i've done but
i'm not sure it's for me in the long run
for two reasons
first if you compare it to doing a
podcast
podcasting has greater reach than
clubhouse so i would rather put time
into my podcast
but then also my like core
asset so to speak is i'm a very fast
reader
so audio per se is not necessarily to my
advantage i don't speak or listen
faster than other people in fact i'm a
slower listener because i like 1.0
not 1.5 x so i should spend less time on
audio and more time reading and writing
yeah it's interesting because you like
you mentioned podcasts and audiobooks
i you know the the
podcasts are recorded and so i can skip
things
like i can skip commercials uh or i can
skip parts where it's like ugh this part
is boring with live conversations
especially when there's a magic to the
fact when you have a lot of people
participating in that conversation
but you know some people are like ugh
this topic
they're going into this thing and you
can't skip it or you can't fast forward
you can go one
1.5 x or 2x you can't speed it up
nevertheless there's a tension between
that so that's the productivity aspect
with the actual magic of live
communication where anything can happen
where
elon musk can ask the ceo of robin hood
vlad
about like hey somebody like holding a
gun to your head there's something shady
going on
the magic of that that's also my
criticism of like uh there's been a
recent conversation with bill gates
that uh he won a platform uh
and had a basically a regular interview
on the platform
without allowing the possibility of the
magic of the chaos like
uh so i'm not i'm not exactly sure
it's probably not the right platform for
you and for many other people who are
exceptionally productive in other places
but there's still nevertheless a magic
to the chaos that could be created with
a live conversation
that gives me pause maybe what it's
perfect for is the tribute
so they had an episode recently that i
didn't hear but i heard it was wonderful
it was anecdotes about steve jobs that
you can't do one to one right and you
don't want control
you want different people appearing and
stepping up and saying they're bit
yeah and clubhouse is 110 perfect for
that
the tribute i love that that should be
but there's also the possibility
i think there was a time when somebody
arranged a conversation with steve jobs
and bill gates on stage right
i remember that happened a long time ago
and you know it was very formal
you know it could have probably gone
better but it was still magical to have
these people that
obviously like had a bunch of tension
throughout their history
there's it's so frictionless to have two
major figures in world history just jump
on
a clubhouse stage putin and elon musk
food you know what happens
and then that's exactly it so there's a
language barrier there there's also
the problem that in particular
it's like like biden would have a
similar problem it's like they're just
not
into new technology so it's very hard to
catch the kremlin up to
first of all twitter right uh but to
catch them up to clubhouse you have to
have the
elon musk has a sense of the internet
the humor the memes and all that kind of
stuff
that you have to have in order to to
like use a new app
and figure out like the timing to beat
what is this thing about
you know so that that's the challenge
there but that's exactly it that that
magic of have two big personalities
just show up and i i i wonder if it's
just a temporary thing that we're going
through with the pandemic
where people are just lonely
and they're seeking for that human
connection that we usually guess get
elsewhere through our work
but they'll stay lonely in my opinion
you think so i do
so it is a pandemic thing but i think it
will persist
and the idea of wanting to be connected
to more of the world clubhouse will
still offer that
and all the mental health issues out
there a lot of people have broken ties
and they will still be lonely
post-vaccines
you